now that we've set up the parameter the
parameterization let's try to evaluate
the integral and the next thing we'll do
is essentially try to express ds right
over here in terms of du and dv and
we've seen this before ds is going to be
equal to the magnitude of the cross
product of the partial of r with respect
to u
crossed with
the partial of r with respect to v
d u
dv so first let's take the cross product
and we'll do that with a three by three
matrix i'll do that right over
right over here
we set up and i i'll just kind of fill
in what r sub u and r sub v is in the
actual determinant right over here so
first we have our components i
j
and k
and now first let's think about what
let's think about what r sub u is the
partial of r with respect to u
well its i component is going to be one
the partial of u with respect to u is
just one so its i component is one its j
component is going to be zero partial of
v with respect to
u is zero v does not change with respect
to u so this is going to be zero
partial of this should be parenthesis
around here partial of this with respect
to u is just going to be one again this
is the partial of v squared with respect
to u is just zero so this is just one
again and then
r sub v the partial of r with respect to
e the i component is going to be zero
j component is going to be one and the
partial of u plus v squared with respect
to v is going to be
is going to be 2v so it's a pretty
straightforward determinant so let's try
to evaluate so the i component it's
going to be i
so we cross out this column this row
it's going to be 0 times 2v
minus 1 times 1. so essentially just
going to be negative 1 times i
so we're going to have negative i so
this is equal to negative
i
and then the j component and we're going
to put a negative out front because
remember we do that checkerboard pattern
so cross out that row that column 1
times 2v is 2v
let me make sure i get that 1 times 2v
is 2v minus 0 times 1. so this is going
to be 2v but since but since it was a
the j component which is going to be
negative it's going to be negative 2vj
negative 2vj let me make sure i did that
right if you that column that row 1
times 2v is 2v minus 0 is 2v the
checkerboard pattern you'd have a
negative j so you have negative 2 v j
and then we have find the k component
cross out that row that column 1 times 1
minus 0. so it's going to be plus
plus k so if we want the magnitude of
this
this whole thing right over here is just
going to be is just going to be the
square root
the square root i'm just taking the
magnitude of this part right over here
the actual cross product
is going to be of negative 1 squared
which is just 1
plus negative 2v squared which is 4 v
squared plus 1 squared which is just 1.
so this whole thing is going to evaluate
2
is going to evaluate 2
we have 2
plus 2
v squared
d u
dv
and if we want to
actually i almost made a mistake that
would have been a disaster 2 plus 4 v
squared 2 plus 4 v squared
d u
dv
and if we want maybe it'll help us a
little bit if we factor out a 2 right
over here so this is the same thing as
we can factor out this is the same thing
as
2 times 1 plus 2 v squared
d u
dv if you factor out the 2 you get this
is equal to the square root of 2
times
times the square root
of 1 plus 2 v squared d u
dv
and i now think we are ready to evaluate
the surface integral so let's do it all
right so we can let me just write this
thing down here so i'm going to write
everything that has to do with v i'm
going to write in purple
so
i'm just going to write the ds part
right over here it is the square root of
2 square root of 2 times the square root
of 1 plus 2 v
squared
and then we're going to have d u which
i'll write in
green
d u
and then dv
dv so this is just the ds part this is
just the ds now we have the y right over
here y is just equal to v
well so i'll write that in purple so y
is just equal to v
that is y let me make it very clear and
all of this
is d s
all of this is d s and now i can write
the bounds in terms of u and v
and so
the u part u is the same thing as x it
goes between 0 and 1
goes between 0 and 1. and then v
v is the same thing as y and it goes and
y goes between or v goes between zero
and two
zero and two and i now think we're ready
to evaluate
and so and the u and v variables are not
so mixed up so we can actually separate
out these two integrals make this a
product of two single integrals the
first thing if you look at it with
respect to d u all the stuff in purple
is just a constant with respect to u so
we can take it out of the du integral we
can take all of this purple stuff out of
this du integral and so this double
integral simplifies to the integral from
0 to 2
of i'll write it as the square root of 2
v
times the square root of 1 plus 2 v
squared and then so i factored out all
of this stuff and then you have times
the integral from 0 to 1
d
u
and then times d
and then you have dv
dv
now this was really complicated i could
say okay this is just going to be a
function of u it's a constant with
respect to v and you could factor this
whole thing out and separate the
integrals but this is even easier this
integral is just going to evaluate to 1.
so this whole thing just evaluates to 1.
and so we've simplified this into one
single integral so this simplifies to
and i could even take the square root of
2 out front the square root of 2 times
the integral from v is equal to 0 to v
is equal to 2 of v
times the square root of
1 plus 2 v squared
dv and so we really are in the home
stretch of evaluating the surface
integral
and here this is basic this is actually
a little bit of u substitution that we
can do in our head you have a function
or this kind of this embedded function
right here 1 plus 2v squared what's the
derivative of 1 plus 2 v squared well it
would be 4v we have something almost 4v
here we can make this 4v by multiplying
it by 4 here and then dividing it by 4
out here this doesn't change the value
of the integral and so now this part
right over here it's pretty
straightforward to take the
anti-derivative
the anti-derivative of this
is going to be we have this
this embedded function's derivative
right over here so we can kind of just
treat it like a like an x or v take the
anti-derivative with respect to this
thing right over here and we get this is
essentially one plus two v squared to
the one-half power we increment it by
one so it's one
plus two v squared to the three halves
power and then you divide by three
halves or you multiply by two-thirds so
times two-thirds
two-thirds so this is the
anti-derivative of that and then of
course you still have all of this stuff
out front
square root of two
over
over four
square root of two over four and we are
going to evaluate this
evaluate this from zero from zero to two
and actually just to simplify it let me
factor out the two thirds so we don't
have to evalu worry about that at two
and zero so i'm going to factor out the
two thirds so times two over three and
actually this will cancel out that
becomes a 1 that becomes a 2. and so we
are left this stuff over here is 1 6
1 6 times and now if you evaluate this
at 2 you have 2v squared that's going to
be 2 times 4 is 8 plus 1 is 9
9 to the 3 halves power so 9 to the one
half is 3 3 to the third is 27 so it's
going to be equal to 27
27 and then minus this thing evaluated
at zero well this is valued at zero is
just going to be one one of the three
halves is just one so minus one and so
this gives us oh i almost made a mistake
there should be square root of two up
here square root of two square root of
two over 6 times 27 minus 1.
so drum roll this gives us the value of
our surface integral is let's see 27
minus 1 is 26
so we get 26 times the square root of 2
over 6. we can simplify a little bit
more divide the numerator and
denominator by 2
and you get
you get 13
square roots of 2
over 3.
and we are done